Celli back to Eric chern quick snapshot blocked
by the New Jersey Captain heer ball settles it
down for the Devils near side this is Eric holla
holla carries the puck in in the middle drops it
off C and is Mercer and he shoots and scores
from the corner Dawson merer Banks one off
of vas liny and the Devils score first one
nothing now lightning are on a line change
here so watch all of a sudden you'll see three
jerseys come into the middle of the ice it's
the point line trying to get out there in time
but they can't quite get there and Mercer who's
got the speed and he had the guts to play
that game of chicken he comes in around the
outside and he just hangs on and then he gets
that's just just a good reaction play When the
guys are past the net they just try to bank
it in off the goal tender vassi was trying to
duck It Lindy started as a defenseman became a
forward but he gives rookies a lot of slack he
says we know we're going to have to live with some
mistakes but that's how you produce real players
perix shoots defected and they score this one's
tipped in front I Believe by Luke Glend Denning
tie game wins the face off he's the best on the
lightning he gets some help winning the face off
then they get two bodies to go to the front of
the net Watson will get an assist on that one
because he's the one that helped get it from the
net smart shot by perik it wasn't even going on
net baly kill for the lightning is
very good at home sixth overall the
power play for the Devils just
like the lightning is very good
shorthanded goal and the lightning
has the lead it's Glen Denning again
he over skates the puck Glen Denning is right
there and then he falls on top of it and then
Glen Denning smart enough to not try to make
any fancy moves get it and take the shot and
he beat them I think in between the arm and
the body yeah Hughes just completely blew
that one yeah it was I thought so right
under the elbow save by basinski chance
to get it out and they do here comes
hangle down the ice Brandon hangle in
stopped by V rebound Puck stays alive in
behind the net battling for that one with
stelli it's Works down along the side
wall to CRA he'll Bank it back to the
point stanos Off the Bench walks it
along the blue line up top to perix
calling for his KRA the Middle Point score
bred point one time from the slot 3-1 Tampa
Bay ex man out there with the goal tender pulled
actually gave Braden Point more room New Jersey
was trying to touch that puck desperately and
they had two guys move over towards CRA and that's
exactly what he wants two players coming over look
at the room for brayen point he was hitting that
one from the ladies teas and he wasn't going to
miss that one beautiful Ed with some space Fe it
back that low for Michael moud back pass and
Brad got his stick on that and it goes right
back to the Devils to Foley back across Slap Shot
from Marino sto by vasilki rebound is in it took
a bounce off the end boards and that's the second
time tonight they have banked one off of baseski
into the net it's 3-2 who should get credit for
this brat was there in front but Cloud was the one
who was working from behind the net to the side
of the net and this one crawled up and over off
the crossbar I'm going to take another look at
this one did brat hit this in the air yeah see
cuz it's McLoud I thought it was mccloud's goal
there's Bassie he gets deflected wide comes off
the end wall oh G McLoud never even touched it
we'll see on a power play goal here's headman
picks up the puck after the initial clear by the
Devils COV with Pace kov in spal ro oh he got a
shot away what a save by vanich he's going to go
one-on-one against Smith and then Brendan Smith
just kind of tweaks him up enough but it was good
on call I guess Gonzales hangs out on the ice they
play together at Syracuse for the majority of this
season now almost up here connecting on a goal in
the National Hockey League this one's turn over
baset in scores a tough turnover by perck ends
up in the back of the net and the Devils have
tied it when forwards for check in a situation
like this all they have to do is guess right if
they guess right you get a chance like this and
then you pay it off that's what basan does if he
had guessed wrong or perix had made the safe play
this would have been a play nobody would have
given g a second thought about Mercer quickly
across to holla holla finds the late man racing
in there is the captain heer back to Halla shot
hits the post and out on the attack they're inth
now calm nice play not into the slot they didn't
rush it after Tampa Bay had open up their two-goal
lead in the goal by points now another turnover
to nemit nemit on the back end curls back in the
corner he'll get into the line there's a shot by
Smith it's on net basosi can't control it and
it is in not clearing guys out so the offside
play who brought it back in definitely they
had a man caught inside if the lightning had
brought it back in it would not be offside but
I do think that maybe New Jersey had brought it
back in here that's nemit yeah I I think this is
going to be ruled and offside There's the Man way
offside that was a conclusive look as far
as I'm concerned if if it gets rolled back
the way we think after coach's challenge video
review it was determined that at 1356 the play
was offside we have no goal coov to open space but
it ends up with the devil's ball with a lead pass
it's brat in STO by baseli he reaches back and
keeps it out and keeps it a tie game on Jasper
brat 66% he was 60% last season and
there's a turnover here's a chance oh
and a save by vanage on St goes he got
a piece for che really Nick Paul doing
a heck of a job against Marino and then
stammer knocks it out of the air and then
stammer knows what to do with it when he
gets he got up ended there too I thought
that could have been a penalty but good job
it's a one-w punch of Paul and then Stam
Coast Eric holl with a shot it's right on
and baski again keeps that moving after the
save C picking his way slowly up
the ice Nikita COV now what's he
going to do COV to radish radish
back to COV TR to cut in KRA with
the back hand pulls it back still
with it gets it arounders his shot
SC Darren radish with a lightning strike in
overtime buls win it confidence that he got
from the two goals that he scored in that
Minnesota game is really starting to show
a dynamic shooter really pays it off but again
it's 86 who sets it all up two sets of eyes go
to him and that allows radish time and room to get
open and that's all coov needs somebody get open
I'll find you and then radish takes good aim and
he's got a rifle of a shot and there you go and
how about that backto back overtime goals from
defenseman perck on Tuesday radish on Thursday